when her mum got sick Denise gave up her
job to look after her but that also
meant giving up her livelihood and with
no financial support from the government
her savings were quickly drained we rely
absolutely holy and solely on mum's
state pension and her disability
benefits not building up any savings
you're not paying anything into a
pension fund
you are thinking well what what happens
and also what what what happens when
when mum does pass there's another one
concerns shared by millions of other
unpaid carers who like Denise can't fit
work with caring though their labor
campaigners say props up Social care the
system would absolutely collapse without
unpaid family carers at 7 million across
the UK and they are providing all manner
of support and otherwise people would be
in hospital they would need far more
help from local government from social
care sources
all right despite that about half of
unpaid carers don't get any state
support and those that qualify get just
under 70 pounds a week compensation that
PSA doesn't match their contribution
unpaid carers are filling the void in
government social care according to a
new report by the House of Lords and
that is putting Financial physical and
emotional pressure on those carers who
the report says are at a Breaking Point
but the government says they are giving
support telling us in a statement since
2010 we have increased carers allowance
putting an additional 800 pounds a year
in Cara's Pockets while the amount
someone can earn while remaining
eligible for the support has increased
by around a third in that period
the cost of caring though is not just
Financial I always feel very guilty
that she's had to give up so much for me
she's not got any social life she's
hasn't had the prob the prospects
of of her career as as she could have
had she has had to give up an awful lot
for me
a feeling of guilt that many of those
cared for share
Sky News